my name is Tinker Hatfield for Wired
magazine all these years that I've been
designing products and some of them have
been in fairly important products here
and there I've never been asked to draw
a cover of magazine I'm fortunate to
have the ability to draw quickly I guess
you could say sort of externalize what's
in my head
sketching is great for me because other
people can generally read the statistics
there's a lot of information in a
well-done sketch our supreme leader at
Nike mark Parker is a creative guy he's
a designer so we go back and forth and
we we since get just to one another
until 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning on a
regular basis so I've adopted that as a
primary tool for moving through the
early phases of a project and I'll make
notes all around this get just one
sketch leads to another and you know I'm
kind of having in a sense a conversation
with myself the most recent one is the
the actual shoe that laces itself or we
call it hyperadapt 1.0 I wrote on the
cover of this projects inspired by
movies robots and bugs I think myself as
a problem solver and as in there quite
frankly a storyteller and I think that's
what I did for your cover is that I
think I solve some problems and hold
some stories so cool that's cool for me
a blank piece of paper is like an
invitation to jump into the future
because it's like it's like a portal how
do you jump through it you fill it up
and somehow when you fill it up with
sketches and notes it's like jumping
through it to the next page